good afternoon president salave
Marta Moret colleagues and friends and
welcome to the Tanner lecture on human
values hosted by the Whitney Humanities
Center my name is Alice Kaplan and I'm
director of the Whitney
one of the Privileges and Pleasures at
the Whitney is to advise the president
on the selection of Tanner lecturers
this year we've had the exceptional
opportunity to invite a speaker working
in the field of artificial intelligence
FeFe Li is an international leader in
establishing a human-centered framework
for artificial intelligence in research
education practice and policy her visit
to Yale is especially meaningful for us
at the Whitney of course because it's
our first Tanner lecture since the
pandemic and our first here in the
humanities quadrangle but also because
it's allowed us to reach deep into our
mission to blend ways of knowing as
we've made contact with a community of
Scholars working in artificial
intelligence and related fields across
the campus we've said to many of you
that we are new to the neighborhood of
artificial intelligence and delighted to
be here
I'm especially grateful to our dean of
the faculty of Arts and Sciences to Mark
gendler to Gary Tomlinson former Whitney
director and Sterling professor of music
and Humanities and to Alan Gerber
Sterling professor of political science
director of the institution for social
and public policy studies professor of
economics and statistics in data science
for their knowledge and their support in
planning this event
before we begin let me say a few words
about the Tanner lectures on human
values which were established by The
American Scholar industrialist and
philanthropist Obert Clark Tanner and
his wife Grace Tanner
educated at the University of Utah
Stanford and Harvard oberd Tanner went
on to become a new testament scholar and
professor at the University of Utah but
that is not the whole story
in order to pay for his education he
founded a jewelry company while still an
undergraduate his company OC Tanner
which manufactures employee recognition
Awards and seeks to improve workplace
cultures through personalized employee
recognition became an extraordinary
success and it is on this base that
Grace and Obert Tanner's philanthropy
was built Yale is one of a number of
universities in the U.S the UK and
Beyond to sponsor Tanner lectures
appointment as a Tanner lecturer is a
recognition of uncommon achievement and
outstanding ability in the field of
human values the lecturers come from
many fields and walks of life philosophy
religion and the other Humanities The
Sciences the creative arts the Learned
professions or indeed from leadership in
public or private Affairs the
lectureships are international and
Intercultural and are meant to transcend
ethnic National Religious and
ideological distinctions
as I noted earlier at Yale Tanner
lecturers are selected by the president
in consultation with the director and
the executive committee of the Whitney
Humanities Center
we are thrilled though not at all
surprised by this big turnout Yale is
obviously delighted that President
salave invited Fife Lee Sequoia
professor of computer science at
Stanford University and Denning
co-director of the Stanford Institute
for human-centered AI
you'll hear more about Professor Lee's
achievements and the impact of her work
in a moment please note that there will
be no question and answer period
following the lecture the video
recording will be posted on the Yale
YouTube channel in the coming days and
we invite you to check the Whitney
Humanities Center website and subscribe
to our weekly email at
subscribe.yale.edu for updates
now it is my pleasure to Welcome to the
podium Professor Marvin Chun Richard M
Colgate professor of psychology and
professor of Neuroscience Marvin it's
such a pleasure after having worked with
you in your capacity as dean of the
college to welcome you today as a leader
in the study of brain Imaging and
artificial intelligence
uh good afternoon everyone Dr FeFe Lee
is one of the most important and
influential researchers in the entire
history of artificial intelligence
if you enjoy the ability to use verbal
labels to search through your library of
thousands of photos or trust your Tesla
to maintain its Lane and speed as it
races along with other cars down a
highway then you owe much to Dr Lee an
AI system is only as good as a data used
to train it and amongst her many
accomplishments she is responsible for
developing imagenet a labeled database
of images that enabled revolutionary
advances in computer vision over the
past 10 to 15 years
even though I'm not a computer scientist
I'm deeply honored to have this
opportunity to introduce Dr Lee because
of our shared background in cognitive
Neuroscience especially seeing
perception and categorization a topic to
which Dr Lee has made pioneering
contributions even before developing
imagenet her broad research interests
then cognitively inspired AI machine
learning deep learning computer vision
and AI plus Health Care especially
ambient intelligence systems for
healthcare delivery
Dr Lee has published more than 200
scientific articles in top tier journals
and Conference proceedings even more
impressive is her measurable impact with
a total of over 181
000 citations her work attracts more
attention in one year than most
researchers gain over their entire
careers
not surprisingly she has been recognized
with countless honors and awards
including election to the National
Academy of engineering the National
Academy of Medicine and the American
Academy of Arts and Sciences
I not only admire her accomplishments in
research but her contributions to
society she is a national leading voice
for advocating diversity in stem and AI
after serving as a director of
Stanford's AI lab she took a sabbatical
from Stanford to serve as the vice
president at Google and as Chief
scientist of AI machine learning at
Google Cloud
now Professor Lee is the co-director of
Stanford uh human-centered AI Institute
and Beyond campus she is co-founder and
chairperson of the national non-profit
AI for off aimed at increasing inclusion
and diversity in AI education
recognized in 2016 by the Carnegie
Foundation as one of the great
immigrants the pride of America
if you consider other past honorees on
this list I can describe Dr Lee to be
like the Albert Einstein or the Yo-Yo Ma
of artificial intelligence
we are excited excited to hear her speak
to us about what we see and what we
value AI with a human perspective please
join me in welcoming this year's Whitney
Humanities Center Tanner lecture on
human values Dr Faye fayley
it's quite an honor to be here I really
want to thank president president Salome
and the Whitney Humanities Center from
quite an honor
of course I cannot pass the opportunity
to also honor another incredible
computer scientist who came out of Yale
that is Dr Grace Harper so for all of us
especially women working in computer
science even after almost 90 years we
still are following her footsteps and
trying to live up to the incredible
leadership and and
trailblazing career she has established
for all the women in computer science
and that Journey has been long and will
still continue we haven't get to where
she probably envisioned for all of us
but it's quite an honor to be back to
the alma mater of Dr Grace Hopper so um
I'm here to really share with you some
of my own work in the the field of AI
and I have to confess as a scientist and
technologist when I enter this uh
incredibly exciting but nobody New Field
in AI to two plus decades ago
it would not have been my wildest dream
that how profound this field has become
to the daily lives of of our Collective
humanity and our society so I really
cherish this moment to share with you
what we have learned but really hope to
engage in a productive
conversation with you I understand there
will be a conversation tomorrow as well
and hope to meet some of you after the
lecture so thank you so much I'll begin
my talk
as Alice has said the topic of my talk
today is what we see and what we value
AI with a human perspective
I'm gonna take you back in history a
little bit back in history
540 million years ago
just just a little while back life on
Earth was very different it was all
under water animals live in the
primordial soup of the ocean and frankly
they're aren't that many animals in the
world life was very chill they float
around
and there's something really remarkable
happened it was a mystery in what
geologically consider a very short
period of time 10 million years between
540 million years ago to 530 million
years ago fossil Studies have told us
the number of animal species just
exploded
what happened there were many theories
from climate change to the chemical
composition of the ocean water and all
this but there is one influential
conjecture that has captured the
attention and this was put forth by
Australian zoologist called denju Parker
by studying fossils he conjectured that
the Cambrian explosion by the way that's
what the period was called with the
animal speciation Cambrian explosion or
big band of evolution actually the
Cambrian explosion is triggered by the
sudden evolution of vision which set off
an evolutionary arms race where animals
either evolved or died
so Vision the onset of vision and
perception was one of the driving forces
of the evolution of animal species
furthermore it's a driving force of the
evolution of the nervous system
eventually leading up to very
intelligent animals like us in fact
today on Earth most the majority of the
animals uses visual perception as a
major sensory system to guide its guided
survival and Thrive thriving of the
species and for us humans were very much
visual visual animals our visual
intelligence gets us to
communicate with each other to work to
navigate the world to interact with the
world to entertain ourselves and it's
it's it's hard to believe that we can
live without much of the visual
intelligence
in the meantime
the field of intelligence also started
to evolve in addition to what natural
evolution is in the field of computer
science AI compared to evolution is a
very very very young field it's most
people say it's about 60 years but the
history of computer vision and the
history of AI is very much entangled
just at the very dong of AI back around
60 years ago
there was a very ambitious MIT summer
project
and the MIT summer project proposed by
this professor says we'll use our summer
workers and I suppose they had some
Smart Ones
effectively to construct a significant
part of a visual system or a artificial
visual system within one summer
well that didn't quite happen
but the urban legend goes that this is
the beginning of the field of computer
vision that someone or a collection of
pioneering computer scientists had to
believe that one day we can create an
artificial intelligence system with the
kind of visual intelligence that humans
enjoy
fast forward to the second decade or
actually the third decade of 21st
century Vision has come a long way just
as Marvin was mentioning about
self-driving cars or visual assistant uh
drive driving assistance to image
classification to the incredible work
recently recently by generative Arts
Vision has not only become a blossoming
and vibrant academic discipline but it
also has become a driving force in
commercialization and and Industry
so the rest of the talk is really to
share with you my own journey and
perspective about my field where have we
come from and where are we heading and
also what are the human lessons that we
have learned along the way of developing
computer vision
so one thing that's been really fun to
hear about this audience is that you
come from all walks of discipline and
areas and I'm not going to assume
everybody is a computer scientist or a
student of AI so let me just give a a
very simple definition because a lot of
you probably hear the words like AI
machine learning deep learning computer
vision NLP what are these things well
here's a cheat sheet I'm I'm not going
to go over everything that I won't quiz
you but but let's just get some basic
definitions artificial intelligence AI
is actually a term coined by computer
scientists and Stanford's Emeritus
professor John McCarthy back in the
1950s early early 60s he described this
field as the science and engineering of
making intelligent machines
nature took 540 million years let's see
how long that would take Humanity to
create a silicon-based intelligent
machine and within the field of
artificial intelligence especially as it
grows you start to see areas of
disciplines emerge such as field of
computer vision field of natural
language processing speech recognition
and Robotics and so on and there are
more and more in your Fields within
artificial intelligence or related to
artificial intelligence
okay and you also hear terms like
machine learning and deep learning what
are these things well
consider machine learning the
mathematical language of doing today's
AI in fact there are other mathematical
languages have been developed in the
history of AI but for the for the
purpose of this talk machine learning is
a a relatively young discipline in
computer science that combines
statistics apply math and even inspired
by neuroscience and psychology and all
this in terms of creating computer
programs based on statistical models to
achieve the goals of different kinds of
AI tasks and within machine learning the
latest Revolution is based on a family
of algorithms called neural networks and
we'll get to that a little more later
but you hear neural networks a lot
probably on news these days and also
there is a more a better name now or
less nerdy name for new Network which is
called Deep learning so these are the
words you will hear from me okay so
let's get to the the talk so I want to
share with you three parts of the work
we have done and the first one is
building AI to see what humans see
first of all let's just accept this
humans are incredible visual animals and
we can see a lot in fact our visual
system is very robust this is a seminal
study by Molly Potter back in the 1970s
with her with her colleagues to show you
that
she show you a video and consider you a
human subject in her lab and Nod your
head if you see a person in one of the
frames okay I see all good you have good
visual systems we get that out of the
way and and
but take a moment to reflect how
remarkable this is every frame here is
refresh is only on the screen for a
hundred milliseconds refresh that 10
hertz frequency and other than say me
telling you to detect a person you don't
know what the person looks like the
gesture of the person where in the frame
it is what kind of clothes it's wearing
you don't know if this is a man woman or
anything yet your visual system is
really quick at recognizing and
detecting this object
furthermore by the turn of the centuries
shortly before the turn of the century
neurophysiologists like Simon Thorpe and
his colleagues have also put a speed of
processing of our remarkable visual
system when categorizing complex natural
scenes the experiment he did is to put
human subject in front of computers and
Flash them with complex photos of
animals or non-animals here are some
examples and the task of the human is to
just say yes I see an animal or I don't
see an animal mind you these are really
complex real life pictures you don't
know which kind of animal is going to
come up you don't know what the
distractor pictures are going to be and
in the meantime he's measuring your
brain wave through EEG and as early as
150 milliseconds after the onset of the
visual stimuli he sees a differential
signal in human brain that tells you the
difference between an animal picture and
a animal picture considering our wet
wear here is a lot slower than
transistors this is a remarkable
achievement in terms of the fleeting
speed that our visual processing is
in addition to temporal capabilities we
also find neural correlates areas in the
brain that are dedicated to object
recognition such as faces or places or
even body parts this is a concurrent set
of studies during the time the turn of
the century showing us these kind of
brain areas
so all this is to show you that there's
something remarkable about our human
visual brain and one of the most
remarkable thing is our ability to do
object recognition or to categorize
objects in fact we believe in cognitive
neuroscientists and vision psychologists
believe object recognition is a
fundamental building block of visual
intelligence and for those of us who
working AI especially trying to make
machine C this has become a North star
it's an important ability we need to
endow the machines with so the formally
speaking the task of object recognition
is to show let's say an agent whether
it's a brain or a computer a picture of
an object and the agent is capable of
output the category of what this picture
contains in this case a very cute
Australian animal wombat
you might wonder how hard is it because
you can all do it well mathematically
speaking any 3D object in the world can
render infinite number of pictures in a
2d frame whether it's a camera a camera
frame or your retina because of the the
infinite possibilities of lighting
appearance differences back on clutter
occlusion self-occlusion camera viewing
angles so this is a hard task and now
Evolution has solved it for us let's see
how we solve it in computers at this
point I'm going to bring you to the last
last lesson or
diversion of machine learning and AI
today is this concept of generalization
so for the rest of the talk no matter
what project I'm talking about as long
as I'm talking about AI mathematically
the goal of AI and developing an AI
algorithm is to solve the problem of
generalization what is the problem of
generalization the generalization is the
following
when we develop an algorithm or a system
that that is capable of doing something
in this case recognizing objects or
wombat pictures
our goal is actually
not to train the algorithms so that the
training error goes to minimal
that's a little counter-intuitive
because of course you want the training
error to go to minimal right that's why
you send your kids to school
um
but
your kids will also get get out of
school and go to the real world so what
you really want is once the algorithm
encounter a a case an example that is
not in training but in testing or in
generalization time you want the
algorithm still to be able to do well
you want the testing error or the
generalization error to be as small as
possible in fact the gap between the
testing error and the training error you
want it to be as small as possible and
that goal or that process of of making
this happen is generalization and in AI
or machine learning our mathematical
goal is always to achieve the best
possible generalization
okay we got the nerd talk out of the way
so let's continue with the visual tasks
we care about which is object
recognition in the early days back last
century that pioneering computer
scientists have used there was very
little compute there was practically no
data and we know very little about the
mathematical models so pioneering
scientists have designed hand design
features and hand design models to try
to account for how to recognize complex
objects and
it was a beautiful it was a bunch of
beautiful conceptual theories but they
didn't go very far in real world
generalization around the turn of 20th
to 21st century a new tool emerged and
that fundamentally changed many areas of
AI including computer vision and that's
the tool of machine learning or
statistical modeling so in this time we
start to see a lot of interesting work
of using hand design features or patches
of images but start to use machine
learning models to learn the parameters
of these features this might be a little
over the head for some of you who are
not in computer science but it doesn't
matter all you need to know is that
we're starting to move towards machine
learning and machine learned
parameterization of models something
else important happened during that time
which is
um
which is actually
the availability of data Internet start
to happen and the field of AI and
computer vision start to have available
pictures to train our algorithms on so
in the seminal or early work by a group
of European scientists they created this
data set called Pascal VOC so that the
whole field the whole community of
computer vision field can start working
on the object
recognition problem by using this data
set of a few thousand images and on 20
object classes that was also around the
time I graduated from PhD and became an
assistant professor and something really
bugged me because while it's really cool
we we're working on this North Star
problem of object recognition but we're
working with 20 objects
cognitive psychologists have told us
humans have a remarkable ability of
recognizing object categories more than
30 000 object categories by tender age
of six
so 20 versus 30 000 it didn't fully
compute so my students and I started to
examine the previous work in conversion
in object recognition and realized one
of the biggest problem we might be
facing is not the hand design models per
se it's actually the data we're training
on so in a three-year effort my
collaborators and my students and I went
a little crazy we downloaded the entire
internet we could get to back in 2006
2007 more than a billion images we hand
curated through a crowd engineering
method 15 meticulously cleaned and
labeled images sorry 50 million
meticulously uh cured and labeled images
across 22 000 object categories and that
was the imagenet project and
image that was born with the ambition
that it will fuel compare vision and
machine learning algorithm in a
fundamentally qualitatively different
way and to our I wouldn't say surprise
but we're very happy to see that start
to happen a particular family of model
that did really well when there is a
huge flood and wealth of data available
is neural network models or algorithms
especially in computer vision
convolutional neural network
convolutional neural network is one of
the statistical models developed since
the last century and it's not a
particularly new set of algorithms the
early onset of the convolutional neural
network history began even in the 60s
and 70s and was further refined by
people like Jeff Hinton and Young
and for those of you not familiar with
this neural network model it is actually
inspired by the brain in fact by the cat
brain and the Hubble and weasel study on
the cat visual system so the fundamental
building block of a neural network is a
node a neuron-like node that takes input
from other nodes and sends output and
not only they they take inputs they also
are layered hierarchically so you can
pass information around in an efficient
way so even 10 years ago with the
availability of imagenet we were making
models neural network models as large as
millions of nodes and hundreds of
millions of parameters and billions of
connections and this number is Tiny
compared to today's neural network
orders of magnitude smaller than what we
see in today's computer science
so with the with the um uh help of
computer uh imagenet and the neural
network algorithm we the field of
computer vision started to see success
in object recognition so we're able to
categorize say a picture of cat or even
find a cat in a more natural everyday
photo or some other
or some other pictures of some other
objects such as teddy bears or girls and
a boy or even small objects like dog and
kite
and then a historical moment happened
so for three years after the re after we
build imagenet
we actually open source this data set we
believe this is an important asset to
our community not only we open sourced
it we created an international challenge
to invite researchers around the world
to participate in the object recognition
Challenge and we we curated a particular
task called the imagenet object
classification task with a thousand
object classes and millions of images
and then in 2012 the winning algorithm
of the image that challenge is by
Professor Jeff Hinton and his student
called imagenet classification with deep
convolutional neural networks with this
work and people casually call it the
Alex net because of the first author
Alex that cut the error rate or the
generalization error as you all learned
significantly compared to the models the
previous previous years models and many
people and maybe historians will tell us
in the future many people now consider
this moment and this work the image
their Challenge and the Alex model the
beginning of the deep learning
Revolution
and not all but Alex that is only in the
beginning there has been incredible
progress in the field of uh computer
vision especially through these annual
winners of of image that challenge in
the following years and that Trend
didn't stop image that image that
challenge and the Deep learning
Revolution took the World by a storm and
we see the progress of computer vision
just accelerating and we're very honored
that imagenet has been one of the most
cited work in the history of computer
science and also it spilled over it's
compare a vision as well as AI was no
longer a niche academic discipline since
the 2012 it became a driving force of
Industry a transformative
era of some people call the fourth
industrial Industrial Revolution or the
Deep learning Revolution and
the field of computer vision if you look
at some market research there is
projected tens of billions of dollars of
Market available now for computer vision
and from Tel Aviv to Silicon Valley
we're just continue to see the
blossoming and flourishing of
comprovision startups
so back in the lab my students and I
don't believe that recognizing or be
able the ability to label object classes
is the end of our visual intelligence
right in fact here's a simple example if
I have two pictures and they're both
labeled with the image net classifier
person and llama you would think the
second picture is more or less telling
the same story as the first picture
but the truth is there's a lot more in
the pixel space in fact this is a very
different scene from the for the the
left one and the psychologists and
cognitive scientists again knew about
this before computer scientists this is
a friend of mine and one of my favorite
papers by Jeremy wolf partially because
the paper is only two pages
um he had a conjecture conjectured that
just recognizing object is not enough to
understand and categorize a scene
relationships between objects must be
coded indeed there is Rich relationship
within a scene Beyond just the identity
of objects so my students and
collaborators and I actually proposed
this new work called scene graph
representation where we encode objects
here in pink boxes the pairwise
relationships here in greenboxes as well
as the attributes that defines the
objects here in purple boxes and you can
see a simple picture like this has a
very rich and dense visual scene
representation
and by creating a large data set with
this kind of with this kind of annotated
data we're able to do things like
predicting object relationships in a
scene in this case such as person riding
a horse or person wearing a hat in fact
seeing graph representation is very
compositional and because of this we can
take advantage of the compositional
nature and be able to do something like
zero shot learning which is we don't
have to train every relationship with a
ton of images in this case our algorithm
was able to recognize horse wearing hat
which is a rare event in life
um or a person sitting on fire hydrant
not so rare and in general our algorithm
at that time using single graph
representation performed better that
state-of-the-art algorithm at that time
of course calling out or labeling
relationships is not the end of the
story in fact we humans can actually
tell a visual story when we are
presented with a scene so around a
couple of years ago using deep learning
algorithm my students and collaborators
and I had done a series of work pushing
the boundary of visual recognition
Beyond objects Beyond relationship
predictions into storytelling and
captioning in this case we showed this
picture to a break to a to a computer
and the computer is auto okay
automatically generate a story such such
as a man riding a horse drawing Carriage
down the street and if we push it harder
they can my dancer captions or even
paragraph captions
even furthermore the visual world is now
static
and most of the world is moving and
dynamic so we push the scene graph
representation into spatial temporal
space and we start to work on
recognizing multi-object multi-actor
activities of relationships this is an
example of an algorithm recognizing not
only ping power table tennis players but
they're they're movements and
relationship between the table the ball
the referee and so on
so all this is to show you that the
field of computer vision has really
blossomed and there are so many
interesting things to working beyond my
own lab our field has made tremendous
progress in 3D Vision imposed estimation
in instant segmentation and in
generative Arts of of vision and this
journey hasn't stopped we continue to
see the explosion of computer vision
development
so for this part we have observed data
compute and your network algorithms
ushered in the Deep learning revolution
in AI
but I'm a firm believer that ai's
development has been and will always
continue to be inspired by brain science
and human cognitive science
and here are the collaborators and
students and postdocs who have
contributed to the work I mentioned
earlier now let's look beyond what
humans can see I know what humans can
see as an inspiration of computer vision
but can we build AI to see what humans
don't see
well
to start with we don't know everything
about the object World in fact can you
name all the dinosaurs here maybe if you
have kids but um even with kids I'm
unable to name all the dinosaurs
um and there are tens of thousands of
bird species and thousands of car I
guess we don't call species car types
and so this is what we call fine-grained
object categorization and to be honest
most humans normal humans cannot
recognize that kind that level of bird
species or that meaning cars and this is
where computer algorithm have pushed the
boundary of human visual ability and we
have in our lab as well as other
people's lab created algorithms to do
this kind of thousands of bird species
recognition and this is one of my
favorite work because we scrape the
Craigslist or or Kelly Blue Book to
learn 28
hundred types of cars ever
manufactured since the late I think
1970s and then we take these car
detectors we scanned Google street view
images across 200 American cities and we
learned about neighborhoods we learned
about sociology we can correlate the
recognition of cars with Census Data
like neighborhood education level or
income or even voting patterns so
computer vision just like human vision
is a lens not only to just see what the
world is but to see and and understand
who we are and and the Human Society
so that was object categorization but I
want to push you a little bit because
our human Vision actually the system
actually do have limits and this is a
famous visual illusion test that many of
you know the Stroop test and you know
the words but can you read to yourself
the color of the words not the words
itself so from left to right at top to
bottom I would say red
oh God a red orange orange
green and it's hard right and we feel
bottlenecked and there is a conflict and
here's a related visual illusion to show
you that we have limited human attention
resource so in a in a change blindness
example I'm showing you two alternating
pictures and there's one change in the
alternating pictures another head when
you see the change
oh this is IQ test
um okay so you didn't not as fast and as
much as that that Molly Potter's uh
detecting the person so it's the jet
engine uh
okay let me do it again
right
a huge part right and okay so this is
fun but the limitation of visual
attention is not fun when it costs lives
in fact medical errors are the third
leading cause of death in American
Health Care system and and we have many
situations in the medical
scenario that we need more visual
attention for example surgical
instrument accounting for surgical
instruments there's so many of them
during a surgery and to this day it's
humans nurses and doctors who have to
tabulate and count them during the
process and it dis slows down the
surgery and sometimes causes errors so
can we imagine computers to help if they
can recognize
2800 types of cars or or birds can we
account for surgical instruments here is
a pilot study we did in actual surgical
rooms at Stanford hospital where the
computer vision algorithm is
automatically accounting for all the
sponges in the scene and we can imagine
to take this further and help the
doctors and nurses
so so there is a lot more humans don't
see that we can ask computers to see
but sometimes not seeing is more
profound this is really one of my
favorite visual Illusions and I'm just
giving you the answer right here I
didn't even have time to to test you so
if you look at the top image Square A
and B don't you swear that of different
grayscale values and then you copy this
image and put these two gray bars
they're identical gray values isn't that
crazy because of the context the prior
knowledge of shape and lighting you have
a different way of processing this
visual information
for those of you who are old enough who
are they
Clinton Gore right of course it's
Clinton Igor really is it really Clinton
nagor
look hard
now it's actually Clinton and Clinton
but because of your prior knowledge the
context the hair and and all this you
see two different people
you come with your home human visual
bias
and this is a fun example but bias is
law fund buyers can be hurtful buyers
can harm people and then can
particularly harm people in under
represented underserved community so
computer scientists and poet Joy
bloodwini put this beautifully in an
example in a poem she wrote called AI
ain't I a woman and this is to really
raise their awareness of AI algorithms
in this case facial recognition
algorithms failing to recognize women
and people of colors faces
so AI can amplify human bias especially
if the data is biased and is is has has
issues but the good news is there is a
growing body of work that is seeking to
address this I'm just showing you a few
examples and there's a lot more
happening now and awareness awareness
level is a lot higher
so we talk about bias seeing bias but
there's something even more profound of
not seen
and it's very important and consider the
situations when you don't want to be
seen
in fact it is really important to
recognize privacy is part of human
dignity and it's part of Human Rights
and when we are creating these powerful
computer vision algorithms do we address
how do we address the issue of privacy
I for one do not believe technology is
the only solution to addressing human
and societal issues but technology must
raise to the occasion and participate in
being a solution not causing problems so
there are actually a growing number of
technical approaches to privacy
Computing in computer vision here I'm
just listing a few whether it's face
blurring dimensionality reduction body
masking Federated learning homographic
encryption some of you might not know
all these words but for those of you who
come from computer science and data
science these are just some of the work
that my colleagues and I have worked in
and I want to just show you one work
it's actually not even my work it's
mostly my collab my collaborator Juan
Carlos niebles and his students this is
a really fun work of doing privacy aware
computer vision computing they recognize
that there is a need for computer vision
technology to recognize human gestures
in many applications whether it's retail
store or safety or garage or whatever
but how do we do this in a privacy
preserving way they devised a lens
that actually distorts the input so
instead of seeing humans it blurs the
lens gives you images like this
but
it's not enough to just have a blurred
picture because you still want to
recognize what's going on so they
actually developed a set of algorithm
that's coupled with this Hardware so
that even when the pictures is blur
distorted the algorithm is still capable
of recognizing relevant human activities
so this is a way to balance the need to
recognize what's going on but to protect
privacy as much as possible of course
all this is just ongoing work and this
is a long journey but in this part we
talk about building AI to see what
humans don't see but what we really
learned is that bias privacy these are
the issues AI can amplify or exacerbate
many profound issues that plagued
Humanity for ages so we as technologists
along with other
stakeholders must commit to study
forecast and guide ai's impact on people
and Society in a multi-disciplinary
approach and these are some of the lead
collaborators students and postdocs who
have contributed the work I talked about
in this section
this brings us to the last topic of the
day is building AI to see what humans
want to see
let's face it when we talk about AI
today
the most important concern one of the
most important concerns Society has is
the labor threat you know when we are
building automating machines we're
taking away human jobs be it truck
drivers or Radiologists or factory
workers and we see these kind of
headlines all the time
um I for one have worked in a industry
for the past 10 years that I see
if not I see a different angle and I see
an equally important or maybe even more
profoundly important important problem
is actually the current labor shortage
in many of our Industries such as
Healthcare by next year that's like two
months from now America will be missing
one million nurses and our current
nurses are overworked and underpaid and
over exhausted and these are the issues
are the very human issues that we're
facing so how do we balance the concern
for ai's labor threat which is real and
we need to really think about it to the
current many of the current issues of
Labor shortage or even unsafe work
environments so we really believe and I
really believe there is a verb we need
to replace and it's the word replace
itself
AI should be augmenting human
capabilities not replacing human
capabilities and I want to show you two
lines of work in in this arguing for
ai's augmentation one is backing
Healthcare I already give you a little
bit of a teaser early on that medical
error is a leading cause of death one of
the leading cause of death in American
Health Care system in fact there are
many Healthcare scenarios where we don't
have enough human eyes to see to ensure
the quality and to ensure safety so more
than 10 years ago my colleagues in
Stanford's medical school and I came
together and start to really imagine can
we in this new wave of machine learning
deep learning Revolution and smart
sensors can we imagine
that we use these smart sensors at a ml
algorithms to glean health critical
insights that are important for patients
and clinicians and this technology is
what we call ambient intelligence for
healthcare a couple of years ago we put
our work 10 years work in a nature
review and I'm not going to get into the
details of this paper but I'll give you
a couple of nuggets of what we talked
about the first one is hand hygiene hand
hygiene practice proper hand hygiene
practice is very important to reduce
Hospital acquired infection which causes
tens of thousands of lives three times
more than car accidents on Americans
Road and whether we're talking about
human Auditors or technology like RFID
there are actually more or less
ineffective or too uh
Time and Labor prohibitive so we piloted
this project at Stanford a hospital
where we put a smart sensor on top of
the gel dispenser the sanitization
stations and these sensors capture depth
images that look like the blue videos so
it's more or less protecting the privacy
of our clinicians but in the meantime
our backend algorithms is running 24 7
recognizing proper hand hygiene
activities here if you see a red a green
box it means the clinician is properly
gelling his or her hand before entering
the patient room and the red box shows
that proper hand hygiene movement did
not happen our algorithm performs on par
with ground truth is a lot better than
one three or even four human Observers
so we also um worked in icus patient
Mobility is linked to improved recovery
but how do we know a patient is being
moved properly both in terms of
frequency as as well as other measures
it's hard we're still resorting on human
Auditors and and if you know anything
about the work of ICU clinicians you
know this is they're overworked and and
not enough hours to even cover how much
they need to do so again we put these
smart sensors in in Stanford hospital as
well as a hospital in Utah and start
working with clinicians on can we
prototype a potential AI help here so
here you're seeing that our AI algorithm
is
recognizing four types of activities or
Mobility movements in in a hospital
getting out of bed in bed getting out of
chair and getting in chair and we're
showing that our algorithm is performing
very well against human labeled ground
truth last but not the least there is a
lot more potential in using this kind of
ambient intelligence technology in
senior homes and aging in place to
predict and prevent unsafe events
monitor patients with mild symptoms and
manage chronic conditions such as
infection Mobility sleep patterns and
diet in fact I pay particular attention
to this aging issue because America is
aging the world is aging and we're
having a real labor shortage of
caretakers so can we go A Step Beyond
just passive smart sensors to send
alerts to doctors and families when it
comes to aging
here's a little bit of sci-fi
um because of the decrease of you know
availability of caregivers can we
imagine one day AI in the forms of
robots can also help our our seniors or
Aging in place and here is not to
replace humans human connection human
emotion family is important but there's
a lot of tasks we can imagine robots to
do and it's also remember
there is 18.4 billion hours of Home
assistance from unpaid caregivers that's
not accounted in our current GDP and
guess who it impacts the most women and
people of color so
as an AI scientist I'm extremely excited
to imagine a robotic future that can
help people at home
well don't get too excited too soon
here's where today's robots are we hear
a lot of robots in factory settings
those are very structured and
pre-programmed settings if we put a
robot in an unstructured setting like
this the poor guy can barely put a box
on a cart
and this is I hope I didn't offend any
roboticists in the audience this is we
know that there's a long way to go in
robotics in fact that most of robotic
research today is still more or less
limited to short Horizon tasks such as
placing something or opening a drawer or
a door or
inserting a pack in a hole and moreover
if you look at robotic research and the
papers we publish they're mostly done
our experiments in artificially simple
environments small scale and anecdotal
experimenter picked tasks and set up
lacks standard Benchmark and metrics and
if if we want to connect this to the
goal of everyday robot the real world is
a lot more complex Dynamic and uncertain
has large variabilities interactive and
social and has a lot of tasks
so how do we close this Gap
well if we have learned anything in the
past Decades of the deep learning
Revolution we have learned that data and
Benchmark has has come a long way in
other related fields such as computer
vision and natural language a natural
language processing in fact with this
kind of inspiration we ask ourselves can
we get inspired for a new North Star for
robotic learning and embody Ai and this
is the last work I want to present in
this lecture today is an ecological
robotic learning environment and a large
set of time a larger diverse set of
activities
that is proposed by the behavior project
at Stanford which is a benchmark for
everyday household activities in Virtual
interactive and ecological environments
it's been so fun to work on this project
in the past three years and we have both
cognitive psychologists and Robotics and
computer scientists working together
before we're talking about oh wow this
is virtual world what are they talking
about let's just take a moment and think
at the end of the day what kind of tasks
are we talking about here you want robot
to help everyday household activities
what are the everyday household
activities well let's do a little bit of
an experiment right here I'm going to
ask you about some household activities
that you would like a robot to help you
with just like not or say something if
you like that what about cleaning the
kitchen floor
okay good yeah
yeah good shoveling snow in Connecticut
okay good good good
folding laundry
okay you know I fold a lot of laundry at
home I actually like that time but
anyway robot can do that cooking
breakfast
I'm getting a little bit of a pause from
you okay this last one is the best
opening Christmas gift
uh
okay by the way I don't know if you'll
notice every single one of the images
are AI generated here now human artists
so okay so that's good so this is really
important we are very enthusiastic
technologists but before we even start
our project let's focus on humans and
people and people's need so before we
start a behavior project we actually did
a large-scale user study with 1400
participants from Amazon Mechanical Turk
and uh screen um and curated 2 000 plus
everyday activities that are proposed by
government data and ask people what
would they or how much would they
benefit if a robot did this for them
because it's important to know what
humans need and then we got the scores
we ranked them as you just showed
cleaning we all want cleaning
um
uh but people don't like robots to open
Christmas gift or throw darts I guess
their worry robot would win or or um buy
a ring I hope not so okay so if you put
the top 1 000 tasks that people prefer
robots help they actually do cluster
into mostly cleaning tasks or some
simple cooking tasks or some boring
shopping tasks and so on so that's good
so we we decided we're gonna take the
top ranked a thousand household
activities as the baseline or as the the
activities we will work towards for our
robotic learning project but that's not
enough in what environment we don't want
to use anecdotal small scale simple
laboratory made environment so we
actually scanned 50 real-world
environments from uh from Apartments to
restaurants to offices to stores and use
these as bases for building our our
robotic training world and we also
obtained 5 000 3D object models across
1200 of their categories and these
object asset models cover 30 plus
different properties from you know
temperature changes to articulation and
and deformability and so on now with all
these ingredients together we're we're
ready to make a unprecedented
large-scale simulation environment for
robotic learning simulator environments
are very critical in fact they're fast
they can be used to transfer to real
world they're safe and they are more
reproducible and we can work towards a
more fair data set using simulation and
there has been good work there has been
a lot of efforts in the field of AI in
creating simulation environments and
these are some of the state-of-the-art
simulation environments by our
colleagues in the world
Behavior project we collaborated we
partnered with nvidia's Omniverse team
which is a commercial grade simulation
environment and we aimed at creating a
realistic environment to train robots
both in physics perception and
interaction here I'm showing you
examples of realistic physics you'll see
thermal effects you see lighting and
reflection effects you see fluid
deformability transparency we also did a
user study on the realism for perception
we compared behaviors environment or
stimulation environment against other
simulation environment and ask people to
score the the perceptual realism and
behavior came out pretty well we also
try very hard to reproduce the real
physical the realism in physical
interaction here you're you're seeing
you are seeing robots doing things with
pretty complex materials such as water
fluids or deformable materials so this
is just a very messy nerdy chart that we
put together to show you the
quantitative comparisons of behavior
compared to other simulation environment
and how behavior is more a diverse more
large scale and complex in several
important dimensions of course with the
goal of creating a new generation of
robotic algorithms for these everyday
household activities we want to start by
asking the question how did today's
algorithm do we picked three Behavior
activities store decoration collecting
trash and and cleaning table to
Benchmark against today's
state-of-the-art algorithm this is a
little dentist I promise this is the
last dense part of the talk where we we
use these three tasks and we change
different conditions of the algorithm to
see how the state-of-the-art algorithm
do let me just say that if we do not
give artificially privileged information
to today's state-of-the-art algorithms
the performance is zero
um
well that's actually encouraging at
least that's what I said to my students
is that you you want to be challenging
and this is where we can make progress
but but
of course if we relax and give some
privileged information for example here
we give it what we call Action
Primitives which is for those of you
coming from robotics you'll know this is
a little more just pre-programmed
movements than the performance start to
improve and if you add some artificial
memory to this it'll improve even more
all this is to say this heavy chart is
to say that behavior is perhaps one of
the most challenging Benchmark in
today's robotic learning and we find it
very exciting that we have now this
fertile playground to train a thousand
household activities for robotic
learning algorithms and we're not
stopping here we're also taking
simulation into real world and creating
a scene to seem to real possibility at
Stanford we created a real world
apartment and also have a real world
robot called Marvin working with its own
digital twin in the simulation
environment so that we we are
simultaneously training the virtual
agent as well as the physical agent here
is actually Marvin
um Marvin is very slow but
but Marvin is actually successfully
going to pick up this bottle and with
the goal of sending this bottle to a
trash bin so let's see if Marvin does
that so please bear with me
um remember in this case successfully
will navigate to the trash bin and place
the bottle inside okay so but Marvel is
not successful in many many times
sometimes you navigate to the wrong
table
sometimes it just doesn't pick up the
bottle
sometimes it it didn't manage to place
the cop in the right place so there is
I'm just showing you this to show you we
still have a long way to go together at
you know the cleaning kitchen floor
thing going for for for us and this is a
teaser video to show you our Behavior
project and give you a little more sense
of the diversity of this environment
of all these are our assimilation
environments and with the video you get
to appreciate a little more of the of
the complexity of behavior complexity of
the environments the the the large-scale
things from store to Apartments to
restaurants the kind of different
objects and and of course the website of
behavior so okay so
we started by that Pro robot and our
goal is one day will create household
robot and that's still a long journey
but I'm very excited by Behavior because
it is born with the goal of augmenting
people not to replace people it's large
scale and diverse and it's it's striving
to be realistic and ecological so with
all this work in building AI to see and
do what humans want to see or want to do
want them to do we learn the value that
AI must seek to augment not replace our
individual and Collective human
capabilities and well-being and there
are a lot of collaborators students and
postdocs who have contributed to this
part of the work
so this brings us almost to the closure
of this lecture with we've talked about
three kinds of AI work we have done in
our lab what's most important is after
this 20-year journey in building AI we
have actually learned a lot of human
lessons that the development of AI must
be guided by the concern for its human
impact that AI should strive to augment
and enhance humans not replace humans
and that AI Technologies must continue
to be inspired by human intelligence and
brain sciences and with these three
fundamental human values Stanford
launched three years ago the
human-centered AI Institute with the
support of a broad faculty leadership
across our at that time seven schools
now we have eight schools from law to
business to medicine to Humanities to
engineering and Natural Sciences and Hai
has is a very young Institute I'll just
highlight a couple of things we have
done mostly during pandemic I guess we
have launched the digital economy lab to
specifically put together economists and
computer scientists and technologists to
study the impact of society of Labor
Market of of our economy in this digital
age we have launched a center for
research on Foundation models all the
news generating AI you see today whether
it's GPT 3 or these Dali Art Is by these
large Foundation models and they have
profound implications in in our industry
as well as AI application both from
ethical societal point of view as well
as from technology point of view so we
have professors faculty researchers
coming together to study this we also
pioneered a new way of reviewing AI
research grants called ethics and
Society review inspired by the the human
subject IRB review led by political
scientists the humanist and a computer
scientist
we also have education program geared
towards undergraduates and graduate
students by embedding ethics in our
computer science classes but our
education didn't stop
within the walls of staffer we reached
out beyond the ones of Stafford and
start to extend AI education to
professional audiences like business
Executives journalists
lawyers and judges as well as policy
makers especially in Washington DC but
also at the state and local level and
Stanford was very proud to be leading
the lobbying successful lobbying of a
bill called National AI research
resource and I believe Yale was part of
the part of the team and thank you
for for the successful effort so Biden
Administration launched the national
artificial intelligence research
resource task force two years ago I'm
very honored and humbled to be one of
the 12 people task force and in a few
weeks we'll be presenting to Congress
this new idea of how to rejuvenate
America's public and higher education
sectors capability of innovating and
education in in AI so all in all it has
been an exhilarating as well as humbling
journey to create AI to to enable
machines to see to realize the the
audacious ambition the evolution have
shown shown us for 540 million years to
create intelligent machines in Silicon
but it's it's incredible that along this
technical Journey we've learned more
human lessons and understand understand
more human values that that machine
learned lessons and this is continue
this is only in the beginning of the
journey and I want to thank of course
all my students and and collaborators
for and also some sponsors to support
this research and thank you for
listening
[Applause]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]